supongamos que aquí tenemos algunos
tubos de ensayo y que en cada uno
tenemos soluciones con fragmentos de adn
pero qué pasa con los fragmentos de adn
en el primer tubo y bueno tal vez me
digan que simplemente hay que contarlos
y tal vez si podríamos excepto porque
son increíblemente pequeños y muy
difíciles de manejar incluso si
tuviéramos un fragmento grande de adn
porque miren si por ejemplo tuviéramos
algo de aproximadamente cinco mil pares
de bases eso es aproximadamente 1 a 2
micrómetros de largo 1 a 2 micrómetros
de largo si lo estiramos por completo y
ni siquiera podemos imaginar lo pequeño
que es su diámetro porque simplemente su
longitud es de 1 a 2 micrómetros ese es
un número muy pequeño es prácticamente
una o dos milésimas de milímetro por eso
no podemos tratar de manipularlo
físicamente con nuestras manos o con
alguna herramienta tosca entonces qué
hacemos bueno
aquí tenemos otras muestras pero como
podemos conocer el tamaño de las cadenas
de adn que tenemos en esas muestras
bueno la técnica que usaremos es la
electroforesis en gel que se puede usar
para fragmentos de adn o de arn pero
también se puede usar para proteínas y
cualquier otra macro molecular para
conocer el tamaño de los fragmentos
entonces vamos a escribir electroforesis
en gel y se le llama así porque
involucra a un gel y carga eléctrica y
la terminación forest is se refiere al
hecho de que provocaremos que los
fragmentos de adn me creen a través del
gel al aplicar la carga eléctrica
entonces la electroforesis se refiere a
la migración o movimiento del adn y cómo
hacemos esto bueno aquí tenemos nuestro
sistema aquí tenemos un gel incrustado
en una solución buffer o también
conocida como solución amortiguador y el
gel más utilizado para esto es la
agarosa que es un polisacárido que se
obtiene de las algas marinas y
literalmente es un gel es un material
gelatinoso entonces lo que haremos es
que vamos a tomar un poco de estas
muestras y vamos a colocarlas en estos
pozos entonces vamos a tomar una muestra
de este tubo y la ponemos aquí después
podemos tomar una muestra de aquí y
ponerla acá
y esta la ponemos aquí y todas estas
muestras se encuentran sumergidas en
esta solución buffer o amortiguador a
que prácticamente consiste en agua con
un poco de sal
la solución buffer nos ayudará a
mantener el ph en un cierto rango
mientras aplicamos una carga eléctrica
porque si el ph se saliera del rango el
sistema pasaría a ser muy ácido o muy
básico y eso podría afectar el adn o
incluso puede afectar la carga que
recibe el adn ahora lo que haremos es
que vamos a aplicar una carga al sistema
del lado en el que se encuentran las
muestras de adn vamos a colocar el
electrodo negativo y del otro lado vamos
a colocar el electrodo positivo vamos a
usar de ventaja el hecho de que el adn
tiene una carga negativa a peach es
típicos porque miren en vídeos
anteriores vimos que existen todas estas
cargas negativas en el esqueleto de
fosfato entonces qué pasará una vez que
conectemos esto a una fuente de poder
y este lado sea negativo y este sea
positivo claro el adn empezará a migrar
pero será que los fragmentos pequeños
migrarán más lejos o serán los más
largos bueno tal vez me digan que los
fragmentos largos tendrán una carga más
negativa así que tal vez lleguen más
lejos pero también tenemos que recordar
que tienen más masa así que la carga por
masa será la misma sin importar la
longitud así que lo que determina qué
tan lejos llega un fragmento es decir
cuánto migra en un cierto tiempo depende
de qué tan pequeño es recuerden que aquí
tenemos que la garrotxa actualmente
muchas personas estudian el mecanismo
exacto por el que el adn y otro tipo de
macromoléculas migran a través del
polisacárido pero bueno por ahora
imaginen que éste polisacárido es como
una malla por eso las cosas pequeñas
pasarán más fácilmente que las grandes
entonces si aplicamos la carga por un
tiempo supongamos que este adn llega
hasta acá y supongamos que bueno yo los
estoy coloreando pero en la realidad no
se ven así supongamos que este adn llega
aquí no llega tan lejos y supongamos que
un poco de este adn no llegó tan lejos y
un poco llegó hasta aquí entonces si
aplicamos la carga y esperamos un poco
después de un tiempo supongamos que
observamos esto ocurre esta migración y
entre más tiempo esperemos más lejos
llegarán los fragmentos incluso si
esperamos muchos se pueden caer aquí
pero supongamos que nos quedamos aquí
así que podríamos suponer que en este
fragmento deben de estar las moléculas
más pequeñas de adn deben de ser las más
cortas mientras que estas son un poco
más largas y éstas han de ser más largas
pero estos fragmentos son los más largos
de todos así que aquí tenemos una mezcla
de varios fragmentos largos y aquí
todavía tenemos algunos pero no tan
largos
y aquí hay algunos fragmentos muy
pequeños y lo que acabamos de hacer nos
ayuda a saber la longitud relativa de
esos fragmentos pero como las medidos
bueno ahí es cuando entra en los
marcadores de adn supongamos que aquí
tenemos una solución estandarizada que
nos servirá como marcador de adn
esas generalmente se compran y vamos a
suponer que la solución estandarizada se
separa así un poco se queda aquí y otro
poco llega hasta acá y otro poco hasta
acá ahora de acuerdo a la solución que
compramos sabemos que este grupo
corresponde a 5000 pares de bases y
supongamos que esta banda corresponde a
1500 pares de bases y supongamos que
ésta corresponde a 500 pares de bases
así que podemos usar este marcador de
adn como referencia para medir el tamaño
de las demás bandas por ejemplo en la
muestra azul tenemos un montón de
que tiene un tamaño aproximadamente
mayor a 500 pares de bases y menor a
1.500 pares de bases mientras que la
muestra verde tiene un tamaño
aproximadamente mayor a 1.500 pares de
bases así podemos hacer una aproximación
y claro podemos elegir nuestra solución
estandarizada de acuerdo a lo que
pensamos que ocurrirá aquí que es lo que
estamos buscando ahora otra cosa
importante es que cuando vemos que el
adn ha migrado hasta aquí podríamos
preguntarnos ok y este será un solo
fragmento de adn pero al analizar los
tamaños podemos ver que no éstos son
muchos adn y no están estirados porque
recuerden que incluso algo que tiene
5000 pares de bases equivale únicamente
a 1 ó 2 micrómetros cuando lo estiramos
así que no podríamos verlo a simple
vista eso es un milésimo de milímetro no
podríamos verlo por eso es que estas son
muchas muchas moléculas
en que emigraron hasta aquí aunque no
tienen que ser tan pequeñas para poder
migrar a través del gel ahora tal vez me
digan ok pero espera como puedo ver este
adn sobre todo porque son moléculas
sumamente pequeñas bueno la respuesta es
que si añadimos algún tipo de pigmento
al adn eso lo hará visible por ejemplo
podría ser algo que le dé una propiedad
fluorescente uno de los pigmentos más
utilizados es el bromuro de eti -dijo-
que es un agente intercalan té porque
miren aquí tenemos dos esqueletos de adn
y estos son los pares de bases pero esta
es la molécula de pidió que se ha
colocado entre todo lo demás por eso se
dice que es intercalan t y en una
molécula de adn eso es lo que la hace
fluorescente cuando aplicamos luz
ultravioleta
entonces si insertamos bromuro de pidió
en todas las muestras de adn cuando los
fragmentos migran al aplicar luz sube
brillan por la fluorescencia y así es
como los podemos ver
y bueno así es como se ve en la vida
real aquí tenemos el pozo en el que
pusimos la solución para el marcador de
adn y estas son las medidas estándar que
obtenemos tal vez aquí tenemos 5 mil
pares de bases
esta banda corresponde a 1500 pares de
bases y esta corresponde a 500 pares de
bases y luego supongamos que aquí
pusimos una muestra con otro adn y
después de un tiempo observamos que no
llegó hasta 500 pares de bases pero es
un poco más así que aquí tenemos algunos
fragmentos con un tamaño un poco mayor a
500 pares de bases y mucho menor a 1500
pares de bases aunque bueno no solamente
obtenemos un tamaño aquí podríamos tener
otro grupo que tenga 1500 pares de bases
y tal vez ya han visto esto antes cuando
las personas realizan análisis genéticos
leen una de estas pruebas realizadas
mediante electroforesis en gel así que
ya sabemos de qué se trata
recuerden que esto no corresponde a un
solo fragmento de adn sino que son
varios fragmentos de adn junto con algún
pigmento como el bromuro de estudio así
que son muchas moléculas que emigraron
gracias a la carga eléctrica porque se
mueven de la carga negativa a la carga
positiva y como éstas son un montón de
moléculas pequeñas pudieron llegar más
lejos porque pudieron pasar a través de
la malla del gel de agarosa